In this segment and the next
two, we will introduce a few
useful random variables that
show up in many applications--
discrete uniform random
variables, binomial random
variables, and geometric random
variables So let's
start with a discrete uniform.
A discrete uniform random
variable is one that has a PMF
of this form.
It takes values in a certain
range, and each one of the
values in that range has
the same probability.
To be more precise, a discrete
uniform is completely
determined by two parameters
that are two integers, a and
b, which are the beginning and
the end of the range of that
random variable.
We're thinking of an experiment
where we're going
to pick an integer at random
among the values that are
between a and b with the end
points a and b included.
And all of these values
are equally likely.
To be more formal, our sample
space is the set of integers
from a until b.
And the number of points that we
have in our sample space is
b minus a plus 1 possible
values.
What is the random variable
that we're talking about?
If this is our sample space, the
outcome of the experiment
is already a number.
And the numerical value of the
random variable is just the
number that we happen to
pick in that range.
So in this context, there isn't
really a distinction
between the outcome of the
experiment and the numerical
value of the random variable.
They are one in the same.
Now since each one of the values
is equally likely, and
since we have so many possible
values, this means that the
probability of any particular
value is going to be 1 over b
minus a plus 1.
This is the choice for the
probability that would make
all the probabilities in
the PMF sum to one.
What does this random variable
model in the real world?
It models a case where we have
a range of possible values,
and we have complete ignorance,
no reason to
believe that one value is more
likely than the other.
As an example, suppose that
you look at your digital
clock, and you look
at the time.
And the time that it tells you
is 11:52 and 26 seconds.
And suppose that you just
look at the seconds.
The seconds reading is something
that takes values in
the set from 0 to 59.
So there are 60 possible
values.
And if you just choose to look
at your clock at a completely
random time, there's no reason
to expect that one reading
would be more likely
than the other.
All readings should be equally
likely, and each one of them
should have a probability
of 1 over 60.
One final comment--
let us look at the special case
where the beginning and
the endpoint of the range of
possible values is the same,
which means that our random
variable can only take one
value, namely that particular
number a.
In that case, the random
variable that we're dealing
with is really a constant.
It doesn't have any
randomness.
It is a deterministic random
variable that takes a
particular value of a with
probability equal to 1.
It is not random in the common
sense of the world, but
mathematically we can still
consider it a random variable
that just happens to be the
same no matter what the
outcome of the experiment is.